Vielleicht ist es doch der?
Ich schaue nach.
* Sanfte, arabische Klänge *
Da, ich bin daran vorbeigelaufen.
Da ist es.
Doch beim Olivenbaum.
Saida Keller-Messahli ist irgendwann
im Jahre 1957 geboren,
so genau weiss das niemand.
In Tunesien ist es damals nicht
üblich, Geburten zu registrieren.
Ihre Eltern sind Analphabeten.
Sie leben einen toleranten Islam.
Wir Kinder mussten nie fasten.
Es war klar, dass Buben und Mädchen
zur Schule gehen.
Der Vater trank sehr gerne Wein.
Das will heute
der politische Islam verbieten.
Er hat auch nie gebetet.
Erst ganz am Schluss des Lebens
fand er,
es könne ja nicht schaden,
wenn man einmal bete.
Er konnte über alles lachen,
auch über die Religion.
Das ist das, was der politische
Islam heute leider nicht hat:
null Humor.
Null Humor,
immer mehr religiöse Regeln -
dagegen kämpft Saida Keller-Messahli
seit Jahren.
* Ruf des Muezzins *
Mutig und unerschrocken kritisiert
sie radikale Glaubensgenossen.
Selber ist sie auch Muslimin.
Glauben Sie an Gott?
Diese Frage beantworte ich nicht
gerne öffentlich, denn das mein ...
... mein Intimleben ist.
Ich finde, dass das
die Öffentlichkeit nichts angeht.
Was treibt Saida Keller-Messahli an,
immer wieder vor einer schleichenden
Islamisierung zu warnen?
Und wie kommt es,
dass ein tunesisches Mädchen
in Grindelwald aufwächst?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Wenn es um radikale Muslime geht,
ist Saida Keller-Messahli
eine gefragte Expertin.
Saida Keller-Messahli
ist Präsidentin
des Forums
für einen fortschrittlichen Islam.
Ich recherchiere jeweils
zu den Moscheen.
Sehr vieles, das ich gefunden habe,
hat mich absolut schockiert.
Er ist ganz bestimmt
ein Hassprediger.
Zu dieser Diskussion begrüsse ich
ganz herzlich Saida Keller-Messahli.
Es ist kein Zufall, dass wir heute
hier fast 80 Dschihadisten haben.
Tritt sie nicht in den Medien auf,
hält Saida Keller-Messahli Vorträge,
wie hier an der Kantonsschule
Burggraben in St. Gallen.
Sie eckt mit ihrer Meinung an und hat
auch schon Morddrohungen erhalten.
Oft ist die Polizei informiert,
wenn sie öffentlich auftritt.
Finden Sie die Schweizer Behörden,
die Gesellschaft ist zu naiv
dem Islam gegenüber?
- Ja, das finde ich.
V.a. gegenüber
dem organisierten Islam.
Ganz wichtig ist da zu sagen:
Der organisierte Islam repräsentiert
max. 15 % der muslimischen
Bevölkerung in der Schweiz.
D.h., dass die grosse Mehrheit,
85 % der muslimischen Bevölkerung,
nicht in diesen Moscheen
vertreten ist.
Und auch nicht über die
Moschee-Verbände vertreten ist.
Aber dann ist es ja
kein grosses Problem?
Doch, weil diese Minderheit
den radikalen Islam vertritt,
d.h. einen politischen Islam
vertritt.
Den eigentlich
die 85 % gar nicht wollen.
Die meisten Moscheen in der Schweiz
haben ein Problem,
behauptet Saida Keller-Messahli.
Denn die Mehrheit der Imame,
die in der Schweiz predigen,
seien islamistisch.
Das beschreibt sie
ausführlich in ihrem Buch.
Die Moscheen sind eine
superorganisierte Angelegenheit.
Wir haben mittlerweilen
etwa 300 in der Schweiz.
Es ist also kein Zufall,
dass jetzt in Wil eine Moschee
für 4 Mio. gebaut wurde -
oder in Netstal bei Glarus
für 4 Mio.
Und wenn mir z.B. ein Imam
wie derjenige von Wil sagt,
die Millionen
kämen aus den Mitgliederbeiträgen,
dann gehe ich forschen. Ich will
wissen, woher das Geld kommt.
Wer hat ein Interesse daran?
Saida Keller-Messahli
fordert von der Schweiz
eine Politik der Nulltoleranz:
z.B. ein Kopftuchverbot an Schulen.
Ihre Gegner werfen ihr vor,
sie argumentiere selber radikal
und beschuldigten sie auch schon
der üblen Nachrede.
Für ihren Mut und ihr Engagement
erhält sie 2016
den Schweizer Menschenrechtspreis.
Hier im Hinterland von Tunis
verbrachte Saida Keller-Messahli
ihre Kindheit.
Die Familie
wohnte in einer kleinen Lehmhütte.
Wir sind einfach
und sehr arm aufgewachsen,
Wir hatten kein Wasser,
keinen Strom.
Wir waren acht Kinder,
aber wir hatten liebe Eltern
und eine wahnsinnige Weite
und sehr viel Licht.
Und sehr viel Leichtigkeit,
kann man sagen.
Und das drückt diese Landschaft
hier für mich auch ein wenig aus.
Der Vater war Bauer bei einem
französischen Grossgrundbesitzer.
Von einem Tag auf den anderen
erblindete er.
Saida ist fünf Jahre alt.
Der Grossgrundbesitzer
meinte es gut mit der Familie
und ermöglichte allen Kindern
den Besuch
einer französischen Privatschule.
Eine katholische Schule in der Nähe
von Tunis, von Nonnen geführt.
Das hat mir immer gefallen als Kind,
die Bougainvillea,
das ist so schön.
Das ist noch die Originalblume.
Schau nur, wie schön!
Das war so der Inbegriff der Schule.
Hier sind wir als Kinder
herumgerannt.
Irgendwo gab es
einen Aufgang zu einer Kapelle.
Ich weiss nicht mehr genau,
wo das war.
Er war für die Nonnen.
Für uns war das geheimnisvoll,
weil es ein verbotener Bereich
für die Kinder war.
Wir fragten uns natürlich immer,
was die da machen.
Wir haben es
nicht richtig verstanden.
Inwiefern hat sie das geprägt,
dass Sie eine katholische
Nonnenschule besuchten?
Der Kontakt mit dem anderen
war schon sehr wichtig.
Also der Kontakt
mit einer anderen Religion
und einer anderen Lebensform
war schon wichtig.
Ja, und einfach
eine andere Art zu sein.
Wir lernten hier z.B. Ordnung,
wir lernten hier Sauberkeit,
das war sehr wichtig.
Es wurden uns Werte vermittelt.
Ca c'est exactement mon souvenir.
C'est tres, tres beau.
Hier war immer ein riesiger Lärm.
Also nie Ruhe.
Man kann sich das ja vorstellen
bei mind. 200 Kindern.
Tische auf Mass für sieben Kinder.
Dort stand die, die servierte.
Hier arbeiteten nur Frauen.
Doch dann ändert sich das Leben
der kleinen Saida radikal.
Die Schule organisiert
mit dem Hilfswerk Terre des Hommes
Feriencamps für Kinder
aus armen Familien aus Algerien
und auch Tunesien.
(Originalton) Vor einem Jahr sind
diese Kinder aus algerischen Lagern
zu uns in die Schweiz gekommen.
Arme, kranke, halbverhungerte Wesen,
die das Kindsein verlernt hatten.
Wie diese Kinder schickt man auch
Saida Keller-Messahli
als 8-Jährige in die Schweiz.
Ein Kulturschock
für die kleine Tunesierin.
Ich bin damals
aus diesem kleinen Paradies ...
... vertrieben worden.
Ich kam nach Grindelwald,
mit diesen Bergen.
Es hatte kein Licht,
es war alles dunkel.
Dazu kam eine Sprache,
die ich nicht verstand.
Das war schon ...
Ja, das war eigentlich ein Riss.
Ein Riss.
Was von Terre des Hommes
als Sommerferien geplant war,
endete in einem fünfjährigen
Aufenthalt in Grindelwald.
Die Gastfamilie stellt den Antrag,
Saida als Pflegekind zu behalten.
Wenn ich das dunkle Haus sehe,
kommt mir alles wieder in den Sinn.
Es war eng, etwas bedrückend
bei dieser Familie.
Die Stimmung war selten gut.
Ich hatte viel Heimweh.
Das, was mir mein Leben
in Grindelwald erleichtert hat,
war die Schule.
Die Verhältnisse
bei der Pflegefamilie sind zerrüttet:
Die Mutter ist Alkoholikerin,
der Vater schlägt die Kinder.
Sie verlangen, dass Saida
Mami und Papi zu ihnen sagt,
was für das Mädchen
nicht infrage kommt.
Saida
fühlt sich doppelt eingeschlossen,
von der angespannten Familienstimmung
und den übermächtigen Bergen.
Es war ein topografischer Schock,
weil ich vor den riesigen Bergen
Angst hatte.
V.a. am Abend, wenn es dunkel wurde
und ich ins Bett musste,
musste ich die Fensterläden
schliessen.
Dann hatte ich immer
diese schwarze Wand vor mir.
Als Kind hat mir das Angst gemacht.
Das Pfarrhaus ist ihr Zufluchtsort.
Pfarrersfamilie Lempen
hat für Saida immer eine offene Tür
und nimmt das unglückliche Mädchen
aus Tunesien
wie eine eigene Tochter auf.
Jetzt sehen Sie dann Pfarrer Lempen.
Er war wichtig für Sie.
Ja.
Sind Sie aufgeregt?
- Sehr.
Ein Wiedersehen
nach mehr als 50 Jahren.
Wie zu alten Zeiten.
Ihr macht euch
so schön an dieser Tür.
Ja, wirklich.
Tschau, Willy!
- Salü, Saida!
Es ist schön, dich wiederzusehen.
Das ist herrlich.
Salü, Saida!
Schön, dass wir das
noch erleben dürfen.
Marianne hat gesagt,
ich solle dir sagen,
wie sie sich immer gefreut hat,
wenn du gekommen bist.
Lebt sie noch hier?
Sie ist in Bern.
Familie Lempen steht Saida
nicht nur während ihrer Zeit
in Grindelwald bei,
sondern unterstützt sie
auch später noch.
War er wie ein Vater für Sie?
- Ja, ja, ja.
Er hatte die Rolle des Vaters.
Er hatte diese Rolle,
dass quasi noch eine Stimme
mir gut will,
hörbar wird.
Saida war wie eine Tochter für mich.
Wenn sie hier war, hat sich einfach
die ganze Familie gefreut.
Ja, und diese Freude
habe ich gespürt.
Das ist wahr, Willy.
Vielen Dank für alles.
Grindelwald ist bereits
Anfang der 1960er-Jahre
auf den Tourismus ausgerichtet.
Ein Bergdorf auf 1'034 m Höhe,
wo jeder jeden kennt.
Saida
ist eine intelligente Schülerin.
Das Mädchen aus Nordafrika
ist so exotisch,
dass die einheimischen Kinder
am Dorfbrunnen versuchen,
ihre dunkle Hautfarbe abzuwaschen.
Das Schulhaus ist immer noch gleich.
Es ist immer noch das gleiche.
- Die Treppe dort. - Ja.
Kannst du dich erinnern?
Du hattest Hausschuhe an,
und ich habe dich geschubst.
Dann bist du
nach hinten auf den Kopf gefallen.
Kannst du dich nicht erinnern?
- Nein. - Da bin ich aber froh.
Du hattest eine
mittelschwere Hirnerschütterung.
Dein Vater hat mit mir geschimpft.
Wie haben Sie sie in Erinnerung?
Sehr lebendig, immer.
Du warst eben laut.
Sehr laut.
Ich war ein schwieriges Kind.
Aber es hat Spass gemacht.
Wie war das, dass plötzlich
ein tunesisches Mädchen
in dieser Schule war?
Es war wie ein Wunder.
Alle haben gefragt, warum sie
hier ist und woher sie kommt.
Mein Vater hat mir im Atlas gezeigt,
wo Tunesien ist.
Er hat mir erklärt, woher du kommst.
Die Schwierigkeit war ja,
dass sie plötzlich diese Familie
verlassen musste.
Ja, das war für uns sehr plötzlich.
Ja, für mich auch.
Ich habe am Freitagabend erfahren,
dass ich am Samstagmorgen
gehen muss.
Ich habe noch
deinen Vater angerufen.
Das ging so schnell.
Eigentlich ein Schock?
- Ja.
Die Mitschüler und der Pfarrer
engagieren sich für Saida,
doch die Pflegefamilie
schickt sie nach fünf Jahren
nach Tunesien zurück.
Die Pflegeeltern lassen sich scheiden
und setzen Saida von einem Tag
auf den anderen ins Flugzeug.
* Arabisch angehauchte Klänge *
Es ist eine Rückkehr
in eine fremde Heimat.
Saida, damals 13 Jahre alt
und ein Teenager,
kann in Tunesien
nicht richtig anknüpfen.
* Sie sprechen Arabisch. *
Ich war total verloren.
Ich konnte die Sprache nicht mehr.
Und ich musste
in ein neues Schulsystem.
Ein Teil meiner Geschwister
und auch meine Mutter
hatten eigentlich
die Verbindung zu mir verloren.
Zum ersten Mal habe ich realisiert,
dass mein Vater blind war,
dass er mich nicht mehr sah.
Ich habe auch erst dann realisiert,
in welcher Armut
meine Eltern lebten.
Doch Saida macht ihren Weg.
Sie besucht das Gymnasium in Tunis
und schafft die Matura.
Fühlen Sie sich
mehr als Tunesierin oder Schweizerin?
In Tunesien bin ich eigentlich
fremder als in der Schweiz.
Darum fühle ich mich eigentlich
mehr daheim in der Schweiz.
Nach der Matura arbeitet sie
als Flight Attendant
bei der Saudi Arabian Airlines.
Sie verdient so viel
wie nie mehr im Leben, wie sie sagt.
Mit dem Geld
kauft sie ihren Eltern dieses Haus.
Könnten Sie sich vorstellen,
hier den Lebensabend zu verbringen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Sicher öfters kommen, aber ...
... wegen meiner Kinder,
und jetzt habe ich noch einen Enkel.
Wenn ich hier bin,
vermisse ich ihn schon.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mit Anfang 20
kommt Saida Keller-Messahli
wieder in die Schweiz zurück
und studiert.
Sie arbeitet als Mittelschullehrerin
und heiratet
einen Schweizer Psychoanalytiker.
Sie bekommen zwei Söhne.
Und inzwischen ist sie Grossmutter
vom kleinen Gian.
Was bedeutet es Ihnen,
Grossmutter zu sein?
Es ist schön, das Leben geht weiter.
Und auch der Glaube ans Leben.
Diese Lebensfreude
und diese totale Unbeschwertheit.
Das zu sehen, ist einfach enorm.
Er ist auf jeden Fall
ein Sonnenschein in meinem Leben.
Das kann man gar nicht beschreiben.
Im Jahre 2006 der grosse Verlust:
Saida Keller-Messahlis Mann
erkrankt an Krebs und stirbt.
Wir mussten nachher versuchen,
das Leben weiterzugehen.
Wie haben Sie das gemacht?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Das macht man einfach,
weil der Wille da ist,
nicht im Schmerz zu versinken.
V.a. auch mir als Mutter
ging es darum,
auch den Söhnen zu zeigen,
dass ich trotz der Abwesenheit
ihres geliebten Vaters
fähig bin, weiterzugehen.
Als Mutter von zwei Söhnen lastet nun
die ganze Verantwortung auf ihr.
Seit dem Tod ihres Mannes,
so sagt sie,
sei sie mit ihrer Arbeit verheiratet.
Fast schon wie eine Getriebene
setzt sie sich
für einen liberalen Islam ein.
Was finden Sie zu ihrem Engagement?
Ich bin mega stolz darauf,
was sie macht.
Ich finde,
sie macht etwas Sinnvolles,
etwas, das die Gesellschaft
nötig hat.
Es macht mich mega stolz.
Es gibt auch die Seite, dass sie auf
der Strasse von Leuten erkannt wird.
Oder es kommt natürlich
auch böse Kritik.
Da braucht sie auch jemanden,
mit dem sie darüber sprechen kann.
Aber alles in allem
bin ich mega stolz.
Haben Sie manchmal
auch Angst um Ihre Mutter? - Nein.
Saida Keller-Messahli ist Präsidentin
des Forums für einen
fortschrittlichen Islam.
Eine Organisation,
die für eine humanistische
und kritische Leseart des Korans
eintritt.
Täglich arbeitet sie an ihren
Recherchen über den radikalen Islam.
Manchmal hat man fast das Gefühl,
dass Sie ein wenig besessen sind von
diesem Thema gegen die Islamisten?
Was treibt Sie so an?
Sicher meine Biografie,
weil ich in einer Zeit
aufgewachsen bin,
in der es sehr viele Freiheiten gab,
gerade für die Frauen.
Dann waren noch ein Elan spürbar
und auch Lebensfreude.
In den letzten Jahren
stelle ich einfach fest,
dass der Islam
immer politischer geworden ist.
So war er vorher nicht.
Er war vorher sehr friedlich
und absolut nicht politisch.
Mit der Zukunft
kann man nicht so rechnen.
Man muss einfach
den Moment geniessen,
das Beste machen, was man kann.
Und die Zukunft
ist immer etwas sehr Ungewisses.
* Sanfte,
arabisch angehaucht Klänge *